في مقابل مشكلات بايدن لا يبدو الوضع في
المعسكر الجمهوري سلسا جدا ايضا نيويورك
تايم ستار حتى تساؤلا عما اذا كان النائب
بك في المقرتي بمقدوره تحقيق الوحده
اللازمه لاداء المهام الاساسيه ام ان جناح
الصقور في الحزب سيفرض عليها تغيير خطته
جانب اخر اشارت اليه الصحيفه وهو ان
النواب الجمهوريين من ولايات متارجحه ربما
لا يساندون القياده خاصه ان كانت مشروعات
القوانين ستؤثر على ناخبهم في هذه
الولايات هذا عدا عن ان مكارثي سيحتاج الى
اصوات ديمقراطيه لتاييد بعض مشاريع
القوانين التي تتطلب اغلبيه تفوق ما يحفظ
به الحزب الجمهوريه حاليا هذا الامر سيفتح
الباب لتقديم تنازلات للديمقراطيين او على
اقل تقدير سيفتح باب للصفقات بين الحزبين
بالتاكيد لن تكون مع نانسي التي اعلنت
تخليها قبل ساعات قليله عن زعامه
الديمقراطيين في لسنواب لكن على كل سياسات
السير على الحبل الحبل المشدود ستثير بلا
شك غضبا وبن جمهوريين تعاهدوا قبل ايام
فقط بالعمل على ان تسبب ولايتهم
البرلمانيه الما سياسيا كبيرا للرئيس
سبايدر مان وحتى ان تمرير مشاريع القوانين
في مجلس النواب سيكون هناك عائقا اخر اين
في مجلس الشيوخ مع سيطره الديمقراطيين
عليه
الديمقراطيه دعا الجمهوريين للعمل المشترك
في المبادرات التشريعيه لكنه امر المستبعد
بحسب محللين فلنقسام ليس فقط بين الحسبين
ولكنه يمتد ايضا الى الداخلي احدهما او
على الاقل
هذا هو الظاهر
[موسيقى]